Men är det så?
Nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsatt 160 miljoner.
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rejändes bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skits för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Tjena, idag välkomnar vi Aida Jamal, partner på e-Equity.
Du är ju e-handelsvärldens mest älskade, investerarpersonlighet, kan man säga så eller?
Det vet jag inte, men tack.
Vi som jobbar inom e-handel, jag tror att vi uppskattar att du är så fruktansvärt konkret.
Du är väldigt skärpt, du är alltid med.
När jag skulle ringa dig och preppa för den här intervjun, och detta är en true story, då ringde jag upp dig och sa, ska vi prata lite grann om vad vi ska prata om?
Då sa du, vi behöver inte hålla på och småsnacka en massa.
Här är vad jag tänkte vi skulle prata om.
Och så sa jag, jag kan skriva ner, jag har redan skrivit ner, jag skickar över.
Jag vet ungefär vad du är intresserad i och hjälpte dig lite, jag spar lite tid.
Det tog två minuter det samtalet.
De andra jag ska snacka med tog en timme, det här tog två minuter.
Men vi ska prata om obekväma sanningar om att bygga e-handel.
Exakt.
Lite grann sånt, sånt som är kul.
Och vi kan börja någonstans när det handlar om att ta in vc-pengar.
Du sa till mig att jag får inte säga vc-pengar för alla vet inte vad vc betyder.
Jag blir tillsagd att slita använda så många ord som inte folk förstår.
Men du kan bara säga externa pengar eller externt kapital.
Vem är det som ska ta in det och är det alltid bra att ta in pengar?
Om det är bra att ta in pengar, det finns oftast två anledningar varför man tar in pengar.
Det ena är för att man helt enkelt vill växa snabbare och kanske delar en risk av någon annan.
Det andra är helt enkelt för att man söker någon bollplank, behöver stöd och det hittar jag kanske oftare hos lite yngre entreprenörer.
Kanske inte för att man behöver pengarna just, men för att man vill ha någon bollplank, någon som kan stötta en.
Det med bollplank, är ni på riktigt bollplank?
Jag lever i någon sorts illusion där pengar människor är onda.
Jag visste inte att det skulle säga något sånt.
När ni väl har investerat, är det då liksom...
Det sker väldigt mycket när EQRI kommer in.
Jag tror att, prata med våra entreprenörer, det är mycket förändringar som sker.
Det är inte bara kapital som går in för att bygga lager.
Bolagen professionaliseras på ett helt annat sätt.
Man går från att driva ett bolag med sin polare, som man gick i gymnasium här kanske och hittat lite success i, till att bygga ett team, till att bygga ett ordentligt bolag, med styrelsemöten och rapporter.
Det låter kanske lite tråkigt men vi hjälper till med alla de här byggstenarna som behövs för att skala bolagen.
Vi är en tillväxtinvesterare.
Vi har investerat i 40 bolag, hittat slärt oss mycket under vägen och har byggt en toolbox för vad som är bra att tänka på när man bygger bolag och ska göra dem 5-10 gånger större.
Så vi är nog en bra bollplank skulle jag ändå säga faktiskt.
Vad är det som är så fruktansvärt dyrt?
Du har sagt att det är dyrt att bygga bolag, men okej sitta i ett par möten, det kostar väl lite fika liksom.
Att anställa någon.
Men vad är det som är så dyrt med att bygga bolag som växer?
Jag kanske har slängt i mig att tillväxt är dyrt.
I vårt jobb då, när vi investerar i ett bolag, så gör vi oftast en plan, en femårig plan, på hur bolaget, hur stort bolaget ska bli, hur mycket ska man omsätta, vad ska vinsten vara?
Och så har man en massa antagande i en sån här modell, ofta säger ni i Excel då.
Och det är vissa antagande som vi har gjort som bara är shit, det här stämmer typ inte efter några år, nu har jag gjort det här i sju år.
Och ett av de här antagen är att man antar alltid att ny kundsanskaffningen blir billigare över tid.
Och det har jag fastsäkert upptäckt att det blir den inte.
Kacken går ju för fan upp över tid.
Och nu generellt, alla bolag kanske inte är där så men för många bolag har jag faktiskt upptäckt att ny kundsanskaffningen blir dyrare över tid.
Och man tänker liksom rent logiskt, det ska den ju inte bli för att man bygger ju liksom varumärken, man blir mer känd och man tar ju långt hängande frukter först och sen så blir det liksom bättre.
Men kacken blir alltid dyrare över tid och det innebär ju att tillväxten liksom blir, den blir ju dyrare över tid.
Nummer två skulle jag säga observationen är att man behöver ju en kostnadskostym för att fortsätta växa.
Och den skulle jag också säga kanske att vi har underskattat vad den innebär.
Men man behöver ju strukturkapital, liksom man behöver ju bygga en viss infrastruktur för att uppehålla den här tillväxten.
Allt vad det innebär liksom mer lager, mer personal, mer it-lösningar.
Så det är dyrt att växa just för att man behöver mer OPEX i många fall.
Så den korrelationen, man vill ju gärna se att fasta kostnadsbasen går ner i förhållande till försäljningen.
Och det gör vi absolut, så den växer långsammare i förhållande till omsättningen.
Men jag skulle gärna vilja att den växer ännu långsammare än vad jag har sett.
Är det stora problemet att man ska växa fort?
Du pratar ju typ om att ni är lite framtunga.
Du menar ju typ att man tar investeringar innan man växer.
Vilket många entreprenörslivna företag kanske inte gör.
Man tar det i slutet stället.
Är det det som är det stora problematiken?
Vi går ju in i bolag som redan har en historisk tillväxt.
Kanske att man har växt, men det beror väldigt mycket på, men minst 20-30 % historiskt.
Man kanske får in i IECO och det växer ännu snabbare, eller bygger en stabilitet för att ha långsiktighet i den tillväxten.
Jag vet att du är lite så här, vad är det för fel på att växa långsamt?
Det är inget fel på att växa långsamt, men det finns entreprenörer som gärna vill växa snabbare.
Då kan det absolut vara positivt att få in en extran investerare.
För att till exempel investera mer i sin egen personal, mer i laget, mer i marknadsföring, eller ta vissa risker som man kanske inte hade vågat om man inte hade en extran investerare.
Jag hade jättegärna växt ut fort, det är bara att jag inte vill dela det med någon.
Ja det är helt okej.
Men om du skulle till exempel bygga ett private label, vad hade du gjort då?
Hade du haft råd med det?
Nej, då tar du in en extran investerare.
Så det är liksom sådana beslut som entreprenörer...
De kommer väl till en punkt där de känner såhär, det har funnits entreprenörer på scen här som bara säger vad ska jag göra nu?
Då kanske det kan vara värt att prata med investerare och se vad man kan hitta på.
När är det farligt att hålla på med tillväxt?
Kombinationen av att låna för att växa är väldigt farligt.
Vi har sett många bolag i rekonstruktioner på senaste tid.
Om man läser om de bolagen att titta på deras framtidens balansräkning det är på grund av att de har lånat pengar för att växa.
Man blir nästan rädd när man ser vissa av de siffrorna.
Leverantörsskulder som släpar allt för länge, som aldrig blir betalda, kundfodringar som man faktiskt aldrig ens får betalt för.
Man har sålt produkter som man inte ens får betalt för.
Det låter helt sjukt.
Men det är många bolag som har hamnat där.
Att man tar vissa risker, man öppnar butiker, man bygger lager, tar för stora risker i inköpen.
I slutändan finns det kanske inte den efterfrågan som man hade tänkt.
Att man bygger på optimism men kanske att det inte finns någon realist med i riktigt det man hade tänkt.
Då blir ju tillväxt farligt.
Låtsas att du inte ska investera i någon här.
Är e-handlare liksom korkade?
Är vi liksom lite drivna av ja men jag är så passionerad, jag ska jobba hårt.
Och så kan man inte matte.
Har vi liksom för lite kunskap om basic matte?
Jag skulle inte säga, nej det skulle jag absolut aldrig säga.
Men jag skulle säga att man kanske inte har en förstå...
Vad jag har märkt bland entreprenörer är att man kanske inte förstår cash flow tillräckligt bra faktiskt.
Man är väldigt fokuserad på resultaträkning.
Det är väldigt stor skillnad på att ha en okej lönsamhet eller en bra lönsamhet och på att ha en hälsosambalansräkning.
Men till exempel tecken på att man inte riktigt kanske förstår cash flow är att lagret växer snabbare än intäkterna.
Alltså din lagomsättningshastighet går ner över tid.
Det brukar vara ett tecken på att nu kanske jag behöver fundera på om jag genererar kassa lite eller om jag liksom...
Värje vinst du får i ditt bolag måste generera en viss kassa.
Om den inte gör det, det är cash conversion.
Om den inte gör det, då behöver du fundera på vad du kan göra annorlunda.
Eller om dina kundfordringar ökar i snabbare takten än din intäkter gör.
Eller om du som sagt släpper på leverantörsk.
Det är signaler på att man inte riktigt förstår cash flow.
Eller om du tar snabba lösningar från Trade eller Gini.
Ingen offens till dem.
Av någon anledning finns de alltid där på balansökningen i bolag som har som struggle.
Det är alltid de snabba lösningar man tar.
Men det är ett tecken på att cash flow inte mår bra.
Framför allt om du har en negativt rörelsekapital.
Jag försöker hålla mig ifrån att säga sådana ord.
Men om du har ett negativt rörelsekapital, då behöver du fundera på om din lönsamhet är tillräckligt hög för att täcka den.
När vi pratade om vad man tog in när man tog in kapital, så pratade de om teamgrejen.
Vilka personer är det man ofta bygger upp i början?
Vad är det vi som vanliga människor eller enare som inte har gjort den här resan förut?
Vad är det vi saknar för kopptens?
Vilka roller brukar ni lägga in?
Bra fråga.
Jag ser väldigt ofta att man anställer juniorpersonal som entreprenör.
Där har vi försökt förespråka att man tar in personer med kompetens och en viss senioritet, i alla fall i ledningsgruppen.
Det tror jag är superviktigt.
Och att man har duktiga mellanchefer tycker jag är väldigt viktigt.
Och att man har KPI på varje avdelning.
Det tycker jag är väldigt viktigt.
Man tänker så som entreprenör, att man vågar sätta KPI på sina anställda.
Är det det som är den stora skillnaden?
Om vi tar, och jag menar detta på det mest kärleksfulla sättet till alla, på något sätt kan man liva bolag upp till 100 miljoner.
Det är ändå så här, på något sätt är världen fortfarande logisk.
Man fattar vad man ska göra och sånt där.
Men om man ska gå upp till en miljard som är, som Jacob sa förut, en nästa logisk steg även om det är långt ifrån.
Men är det att allting måste mätas då?
Är det att man måste fatta vad man håller på med?
Kan man leka lite i början?
Och sen är det det som är den stora grejen, skillnaden från att gå från 100 till en miljard?
Skillnaden på ett bolag som hemsätter 100 miljoner jämfört med en miljard, skulle jag säga att ett bolag som hemsätter 100 miljoner har oftast väldigt...
Går med på markkänsla, shit vad jag har hört så mycket idag av entreprenörer som hemsätter 100 miljoner och går med på markkänsla.
Det är inget fel på det, men i alla fall om vi som ägare...
Jag tycker absolut att man ska ha markkänsla, man ska ha en markkänsla för vad kunderna vill ha.
Det är ingen science i det, man måste förstå vad beteendet är på väg.
Det är lite det som är ett ord som används länge just nu.
Den markkänslan ska man ha, men jag tycker inte att man ska ha markkänsla i vart bolaget är på väg.
Man ska inte ha kapitaldisciplin, behöver man förstå sig på genom att titta på datan.
Om jag lägger en krona till i marknadsföring, eller om jag investerar en krona i någonting, vad kommer det att leda till med så stor sannolikhet som möjligt?
Den analysen gör man baserad på data så gott det går i alla fall.
Jag tänker att många...
Det är en skillnad, en av skillnaderna skulle jag säga.
Ett bolag som omsätter en miljard oftast gör små tweaks, är du väldigt duktig på att göra små tweaks i affären som gör bolaget och affären marginellt bättre hela tiden utan att ta för stora risker.
Och sen är man oftast också mycket mer datastyrd.
Absolut.
Jag bara tänker att det går emot många entreprenörers personlighet.
De är ju ofta väldigt farsamma.
Ja men entreprenörer är inte bara vd.
Jag vet inte varför vi låtsas som det hela tiden.
Vad gör ni med dem?
Eller kan ni såhär, ja stick då.
Nej, absolut inte.
Entreprenörer, eller grundare då, de är bra vd, jag är upp till en viss punkt.
Men sen är det ju dags att antingen coacha dem.
Alltså vi på Eko har ju ledarskapsutbildningar, och inte av oss på Eko utan faktiskt experter då, som coachar entreprenörer i att ta nästa steg.
Kunna ta personalen, kunna ta utvecklingssamtal, kunna rekrytera folk som är bättre än dig själv, kunna delegera och inte ha för många hatar.
Allt det där är superviktigt för ett bolag som behöver växa.
Men jag kan säga så här, nu kommer jag säkert dequotat på detta, men vi har ju sällan ångrat att vi har bytt ut en grundare till en extern professionell vd.
Oftast har bolagen presterat bättre.
Det är ingen hemlighet, det är det många entreprenörer, de vill ju hålla på med produkt, många av dem.
De är visionärer, vi har haft folk här på scen som har sagt exakt det jag säger.
Det är ju en superkraft med att få bygga ett bolag som ska bli stort.
Det krävs andra typer av kompetenser, oftast har jag sett.
Vad är det första tecknet på att en vd som varit med från start, inte klarar nästa steg?
Vad är det de ofta fallerar först på?
Har du någon sådan?
Ärligt talat, det är att de inte är coachable och tror att de kan och vet bäst.
Ja, verkligen.
Det är såhär, ja gud.
Men alltså 100 procent att de inte kan ta till sig andras råd brukar vara en stor flagga för oss faktiskt på Gekko det.
Sedan finns det en lista på saker och ting.
Men jag skulle absolut säga att inte kunna vara coach, att inte kunna ta råd från andra, trots att man har bra argument och massa bra data, men för att entreprenörer går på sin markkänsla, det funkar ju inte.
Jag fattar.
Vi pratade lite inför detta och du nämnde det här uttrycket Customer Obsession här nu, precis som är ultraspämat.
Det är så sjukt spämat.
Precis som community, det är ordet.
Det ser man i varje pitch, sell side pitch.
Jag har det som min bonusfråga är på slutet.
Bonusfrågan är community, är det ett annat ord för rabattkod?
Okej, vi kommer till det.
Nu ska vi se.
Customer Obsession innebär väldigt enkelt att man har en förmåga att sälja rätt produkt till rätt kund i rätt tid.
Det låter superbasic.
Men det innebär egentligen att man har en förmåga att kunna tjäna pengar på en viss kundgrupp.
Att man förstår dess beteende, man förstår dess behov, man löser deras problem.
Det är någonting man konstant ska, det är något som förandras hela tiden.
Det handlar om att förstå ens kund helt enkelt.
Vi på Eko det gör, vi har 60-hälsomöten i varje bolag, om året olika teman.
Ett tema som jag tycker om i de mötena är customer profiles och reach.
Vilka är våra kunder?
Man kan göra service för att förstå sig på sina kunder.
Vilka poddar lyssnar våra kunder på?
Vilka gillar de?
Vilka färger tycker de om?
Vilka värderingar har de?
Hur ska vi kommunicera på bästa sätt?
Det låter superflummigt kanske, men det är så viktigt att förstå ens kund.
Och det är faktiskt här många, även av våra bolag, kanske har gått fel i deras produktexpansionsstrategi, för att de inte har förstått vad kunden egentligen vill ha, helt enkelt.
Så att det är för mig en custom obsession.
Att man liksom skickar annonser i att tid, liksom under den stunden som en kund funderar på någonting.
Men vi har också haft snacket om att D2C är lite dött.
Är inte det en motpool till detta?
Okej, D2C är absolut inte dött.
D2C-modellen är jävligt mättad.
Det är liksom inte så imponerande längre, som det var för 15 år sedan, att sälja direkt till konsument.
Och kunna göra det flexibelt med olika betalningslösningar och alla de här leverantörerna som finns på den här konferensen.
Och kunna göra det med dem.
Alla är likadana.
För 15 år sedan var det supercoolt med influencermarketing och coolt med en skön Shopify-site och schyssta bilder och sådär.
Idag är det inte det, för det finns så många bolag som gör konkurrenserna så är vansamt lite mycket större.
Ribban har ju blivit mycket högre för det-to-see och för att förstå vad värdet i det-to-see-modellen faktiskt är.
Och det finns olika saker som jag brukar prata om, vad man brukar göra, eller vad man bör göra för att sticka ut.
Jag till exempel har sagt nu att content är superviktigt, det är inget nytt, alla vet att content är superviktigt.
Men jag tror att man har gått från att jaga följare till att skapa content som står på egna ben och går viral.
Det är ett annat sätt vi pratar om just nu när det kommer till hur man skapar värde och tillväxt i det-to-see-bolag.
Men det jag vill säga är att det-to-see-modellen är mättad, det-to-see-modellen är inte dött.
Det finns fortfarande ett väldigt fint värde i det-to-see-modellen och det är ju kundrelationen som det-to-see-bolag bygger.
Kundrelationen och förmågan att ta betalt och tjäna pengar på ens kunder över tid.
Det är där jag tror jag vill komma in på community lite sen.
Men det är ju värdet, det är kunderna och den lojaliteten som man har byggt med en viss kundgrupp och att man kan visa att man kan tjäna pengar på dem över tid.
Inte bara över en viss.
Finns det en lojalitet och finns det en community?
Vi kan hamna i det direkt för att vi kör tid.
Men ibland när jag hör alla de här säga att vi har en återkommande kund, fan de skiter väl i dig eller de köper ju där det är bäst nästa gång och så råkar du vara bäst den gången eller?
Community är ett superöveranvänt ord som alla pitchböcker, det står det i alla pitchböcker jag läser om ett brand.
Community är ett finare ord, tror jag, för hög LTV-relation till kack, som är ett inte lika enkelt ord att ta till sig.
Men community innebär att du har ett tillräckligt högt förtroende för kunderna att vilja komma tillbaka utan att behöva se en annons, utan de kommer tillbaka innan att söka på ditt brand direkt till exempel.
Det kan man mäta via branded search.
Du har förmåga att få kunder att komma tillbaka organiskt för att de kommer på dig.
Du behöver inte rabattera för att konvertera.
Du kan ta mer betalt än dina konkurrenter och har en bra bruttomarginal, det är därför vi tittar super mycket på det.
Det får man inte glömma bort med alla andra metrics som man pratar så mycket om.
Det är fortfarande en jätteviktig metric även för oss.
Och visar att du har en viss brand equity mot dina konkurrenter.
Men det är community att du har ett viss brand equity och att du har kundrelationer som du kan tjäna pengar på över tid.
Jag köper det, det är en ganska bra förklaring.
Aida, jag är inte ens halvvägs klar men tiden är slut.
Fan också, vad tråkigt.
Du är en fucking force of nature i den här världen.
Jag gillar det.
Hugg Aida när ni är klara här och så gå fram och fråga allt ni vill fråga.
Stort tack och en applåd för Aida.
När vi pratade inför detta så snackade du om organisk trafik och när man lyssnar på poddar nu för tiden så går 90% ut på hur man ska optimera för meta och hur man ska få den där jävla grejen.
Men ni har gått lite andra hållet, kan du inte bara utveckla det?
Vi optimerar ju också performance på alla sätt vi kan.
Men jag tror det är viktigt för framtiden att man försöker så gott som möjligt minska sitt beroende av de här.
Priserna går upp, allting annat går ner med de där.
Jag ser det som ett egenvärde ibland.
Men det är klart man ska absolut optimera alla performancegrejer man kan.
Berätta lite om era siffror.
Jag vet att ni har ganska stor organisk siffror.
Ja, vi har stor organiska siffror.
Det beror på att vi har varit med länge, vi har byggt varumärke länge.
Vi har olika aktiviteter, vi jobbar mycket med branding av vårt varumärke.
Och, ja men, that's it egentligen.
Och jag vet att vi pratade om en nyhetsfråga, jag vet inte om du vill komma in på det, men...
Jag vill också veta hur mycket av er trafik eller er konvertering är från organiskt föde jämfört med?
Av våra intäkter så är det ungefär 60 procent som kommer från det organiska.
Och det är för att vi behandlar våra organiska kanaler väl.
Och vi tar hand om våra kunder och vi vill att de ska komma tillbaka.
Och vi pratar med dem, vi behandlar dem med respekt.
Och då kommer de mest tillbaka.
Och sen försöker vi ju liksom, det är också ett maskineri som ska rulla och det ska också optimeras.
Men det är viktigt att dela upp.
Ibland kan jag känna att performance marketing och branding, det behöver ibland nästan sätta separat.
Det helst skulle sitta i separata byggnader med separata team.
För att performance, det är så kraftfullt så det liksom tar över diskussionen.
När du får de där klickorna, när saker och ting går viralt.
Men själva branding-biten, det är lätt att missa det, hur viktigt det är.
Ja, jag gillar det lite grann.
Jag tycker också att det har blivit nästan, det är nästan det enda man pratar om är någon sorts ny kundsanskaffning.
Och så bara räknar man med att, jag ska ha någon sorts mejlflöde till de här efterföljande.
Men det är precis samma också.
Jag brukar säga så här att marknadsföring, det som är fotbollsplan, du behöver ha många spelare på planen.
Det räcker inte, många nya aktörer kan jag känna att de har två spelare.
De har Google om ettan, that's it.
Det är svårt att skjuta en boll i mål med två spelare.
Alltså du behöver ha affiliates, branding och event.
Och en anmälning i reklamombudsmannen till exempel.
Allt det här är spelare som skjuter bollen i mål.
Och någon spelaracist, oftast är det Google som skjuter den i mål.
För vår del.
Men du behöver många spelare.
Ja men jag köper det.
Är det det som du skulle säga att folk missar, de lägger för, de lägger all in på en kanal och så kör de det?
Ja till exempel.
Jag tror att många stirrar sig blinda på de siffror de kan se.
Inte på dem de inte kan se.
Är det för att du har hållit på med detta så länge som du känner dig trygg i det?
Ja men du är ju aktiv på LinkedIn och jag kan ju se när jag gör ett inlägg på LinkedIn så då kan vi sälja för 20.000 på det inlägget.
Man ser det direkt i relation till den produkt jag pratar om.
Och då är liksom LinkedIn egentligen inte ens en säljkanal.
Men det är ju ingenting som kopplar mitt inlägg till den försäljningen.
Det kommer ju med erfarenhet att man vet vad som ger och vilka kanaler som ger det och vilka händelser som ger det.
Även liksom makropolitiskt.
När du har varit med ett tag så vet du ju att när Trump öppnar munnen då kommer detta, detta, detta och händas kommer räntan gå ner eller upp.
Och då kan jag direkt relatera till våra kunder då som är män mellan 25 och 55 med ett snitt på 41 år som är tungt investerade på börsen.
Och är väldigt mycket intresserade av it-riggespolitik.
Jag vet precis vad som händer och hur det här kommer att inom 30 minuter påverka vår försäljning.
Jag satt ju och live-streamade Davos-talet bara för att fundera på om vi skulle skjuta på våra dollarbetalningar eller inte.
Man kunde följa i realtid att dollarn gick ner.
Jag är ju redan målgrupp exakt.
Men då får man ju liksom, det här kommer ju med erfarenhet och du har ju oftast varit med om någon smäll först innan du inser och så i efterhands inser man att det talet gjorde att det hände.
Många nya spelare tror att det finns två aktörer på marknadsföringsmarknaden.
Om det finns, finns det massor.
Men du måste också kunna spela dem.
Som lagledare, om jag skulle jämföra med det med det, så behöver jag ta hänsyn till hela spelplanen och den omfattar hela världen.
Som sagt, du sa ju att jag skulle komma in på nyhetsbrev och jag fullkomligt hatar ju nyhetsbrev.
Jag verkligen tycker inte om nyhetsbrev och jag har varit ganska öppen med det.
Att liksom, fan, fan tror ni att ni tillför för värdet till folks liv i den där inboxen?
Men ni är det enda nyhetsbrevet som jag följer.
Tack så mycket.
Jag ska bara läsa några av era rubriker och det är egentligen mest därför.
Ni har bättre glid i helgen, tysk P-mustache är nog min grej, få bukt med pung-svätt.
Vem liksom pitchar de här rubrikerna och vad är liksom grejen?
Är det bara en clickbait?
Nej, vi är ett team som gör det.
Jag har faktiskt bara varit med i det teamet i tre månader nu för vår marknadschef i Mamaledi.
Men vi är ett gäng som gör det och vi har jätteroligt när vi sitter och kommer på de här.
Alltså, vi har tagit mycket inspiration från retail, vi har tre butiker och där handlar det om att först få folk att komma in genom dörren.
Och sen när folk kommer in genom dörren, och det gör det oftast med en skylt eller en gatuprata eller whatever, när de kommer in genom dörren så ska de in i ett kundvarv.
IKEA är mestare på kundvarv till exempel.
Att få folk att lägga till varor, blablabla.
Och sen checka ut så snabbt, för så mycket pengar som möjligt.
Och ett nyhetsbräve är bara en dörr in genom dörren.
Om du klickar på den där rubriken så har vi mycket större chans att kunden kommer in genom dörren.
Rubriken måste vara ett klickbete.
Men sen måste ju både i nyhetsbrävet vara intressant, matcha, alltså uppfylla kundens förvältningar egentligen om innehållen, om klickbetet.
Och sen därefter måste kunden klicka vidare till hemsidan.
Och sen när kunden är inne på den produkten, då måste ju den vara optimerad för att du ska lägga varan i korgen.
Och sen ska du ta den till kassan.
Hells ska du gå via en vara till.
Och så hela liksom retail-bandet.
Så för vår del är nyhetsbrävet en jättebra kanal.
Den är gratis.
Den kommer att altera jättebra.
Och vi drar in mycket pengar på den.
Och det är fritt framför alla bolag att göra det.
Det är bara det att, jag säger det där igen, att performance marketing det bara tar över.
Men om du liksom bara släpper det lite och börjar titta på de tillgångar du har, att förädla de tillgångar du har och framförallt vad målgruppen vill ha.
Målgruppen är 41-åriga män, då får jag anpassa den kommunikationen.
Och liksom, vad är deras problem?
Det är håravfall, pung-svätt, fot-svätt, nageltång, jag kan röra den forever liksom, hår på ryggen, hår i näsan.
Det är liksom, det finns en oändlig pool av ämnen att diskutera och om man gör det med kärlek och med humor, så blir det ett bra nyhetsbrev.
Är det weird att du, vi pratade om det med några grundare här precis, som är några killar som driver ett kvinnligt varumärke och du är en kvinna som driver ett manligt varumärke.
Är det lite weird att, är inte det lite skumt att ditt företag hjälper killar med pung-svätt?
Nej, alltså du vet jag är så himla var på det.
Vad skulle ni säga.
Jag har varit med länge och har omtänksamhet och empati i kroppen.
Så känner jag att, det är inte konstigare för mig än att klappa någon på knäet eller sånt där.
Alltså vi har alla komplex.
Det var genom grejerna när vi grundade Gents från början, så var det ju att, för mig var det så tydligt att, den manliga marknaden var underserved.
På den kvinnliga, ögonskugan för kvinnor, alltså det finns miljoner brands, men du har inte ens en basic huvudvård från man, eller en rarkräm eller någonting.
Det känns som, det är så mycket budget på mansidan, för att män har ju samma problem som kvinnor har, egentligen exakt samma problem som kvinnor har i andra former.
Men det är en tacksam målgrupp att jobba med.
Är det en av era grejer som gör att ni får tillbaka kunder, att ni håller en ganska avdramatiserad relation, alltså om jag som er målgrupp går in och ska hälsa på någon klinisk studio, så kommer jag in där och så sitter det två tjejer där som uppenbart har koll på detta så känner jag mig jävligt lost om jag skulle gå in där och så här, om jag har hår i näsan ska vi prata om det.
Men om jag däremot pratar med någon som uppenbart har lite humor och skämt i det, är det liksom en grej eller är det mer bara att ni har roligt?
Både och, det är en grej vi har roligt, men vi ser ju också att det konverterar.
Alltså ett sådant nyhetsbrev om punkt svetter konverterar ju väldigt mycket bättre än något som är fint väder idag.
Så de flesta nyhetsbrevare.
Vart går, nu ska vi hamna här Jenny, vart går gränserna för hur man ska kommunicera i nyhetsbrev?
Du har fått en del skit liksom i diverse medier och så där, och ett av de exempelna var att ni hade en parfym och det ska man ju säga att det är inte ni som sätter parfymerna, utan det här är ju liksom parfymören som har sagt då att den här parfymern luktade som lyxprostitution och cannabis, eller marknadens bästa cannabis kanske ska tilläggas.
Det var en hålländsk parfymör.
Men då gick ni ändå ut med det som en reklam eller som ett nyhetsbrev då?
Alltså för oss var det inget konstigt, för vi har ju parfymmer som luktar lik och liksom förlossning och allt möjligt.
Har ni det?
Ja faktiskt, samma parfymör har också gjort en linje som är för The Smell of Life.
Vem fan vill ha det?
Det finns ju där liksom jag skall säga, men de doftar inte illa, de doftar rätt gott.
De har bara en twist.
Men för oss är det inte konstigt att vi doftar på sånt här hela tiden.
När man jobbar med våra grejer så blir man lite hjärntvettad och tycker inte att saker och ting är konstigt.
Så det stod faktiskt i rubriken på nyhetsbrevet och då blev vi anmälda ett antal och sju gånger till reklamombudsmannen för det nyhetsbrevet.
Och Felda tror jag.
Men vad känner du då?
Blir du liksom skiggad undan lite eller blir du lite såhär fan det här är inte...
Ja men när första drevet går, det absolut första drevet man råkar ut för är ju alltid jättejobbigt.
Det finns säkert härute någon som har råkat ut för ett rev eller två.
Det är jättejobbigt för man vet inte hur man ska hantera det.
Och varenda ett rev blir lite enklare.
Och nu blev vi ju Felda i höstas också för ett aprilskämt.
Men man får någonstans också vallanda ner i sina egna värderingar.
Vad står jag för och vad står målgruppen för?
Det frågade jag tidigare när man går över gränsen.
Det är målgruppen som säger när man går över gränsen.
När de slutar handla eller när de inte vill längre eller när vi får för många mail från kunder som säger att ni är dumma i huvudet.
Då har vi passerat gränsen.
Jag bara säger det här aprilskämtet som ni blev Felda för, det var att ni skulle boykotta efter att Trump blev vald.
Men Trump hade gjort något helt galet.
Jag kommer inte ihåg vad det var.
Folk var riots, alltså hela världen var ju...
Och då skulle vi som aprilskämt göra en manns boykott mot USA och vi skulle då byta namn på alla våra varor.
Alla våra engelska namn skulle byta namn till svenska namn.
Och så bara gjorde vi en översättning.
So far so good.
Det var bara det att parfymen Bayred och Gypsy Water blev översatt till Sigena vatten.
Våra kunder tror jag inte reagerade så mycket över det.
Jag tror vi fick fem mail från kunder som var arg över att vi hade boykottat USA som inte förstod att det var det.
Där utan sa att ni förstår inte utrikespolitiken när det handlar om Rysslandskänning och boykotta.
Men däremot så blev vi anmälda av någon annan för att ha förminskat minoriteter.
Jag funderade på det och sen tänkte jag att jag är såklart ledsen om någon blir sårad, men jag tror att för våra kunder hade vi inte gått över gränsen.
Det här med att ligga på gränsen, och jag kan ju uppskatta det.
Jag tycker ju väldigt mycket, när jag sa till folk att jag skulle ha med dig här på scen så var det flera som blev väldigt lyckliga, för de hade sett dig och mig i en panel.
Vi var i en panel här för typ 2 år sedan eller någonting.
Då säger jag någonting, varpå du bara avbryter sig.
Jag håller inte med, det där är fel.
Så här gör vi.
Du är ju lite krass på det där sättet, men kan du uppleva att det där är din personliga fight, blir inte företaget lidande av det, eller ska företaget bara slå den fighten för dig?
Företaget uppmanas hela tiden att delta i samhällsdebatten, men det är ju bara slätstrykna värderingar jämt och ständigt, det är sustainability, det är ba ba ba ba ba ba.
Om man ska delta, om man vill vara en röst i samhället, personligen tycker jag att företag ska vara det, jag tycker också att privatpersoner ska vara det, jag tycker att det handlar om civil korrekt, vilket samhälle vill man ha, jag är väldigt intresserad av politik, utrikspolitik och vad som händer i samhället, demokratifrågor och sådana saker.
Och när man ser någonting som man kanske, nu har jag inte de här aprilskämten om det att göra, men jag tycker absolut att man ska delta i debatten, och det handlar också om att bygga brand, vad man står för, och vad man står upp för.
Och det handlar, det är civilkrav tycker jag, och var går gränsen?
Ja, det går ju där din egen gräns går, eller där kunderna ska gränsa, eller är du beredd att offra det?
Jag tänker på det här senaste nu med Antropik och Shetka Peté, vem som skulle serva den amerikanska militären, och hur ryggrad visade sig var det som gick hem hos kunderna.
Och det står jag gärna för.
Jag köper det, men kan du uppleva att det är svårt med personal och sådär?
Kanske de som har känt dig länge vet att sådant här är Jenny.
Men de som kommer färska och tänker att de ska in i ett skönhetsvarumärke och helt plötsligt hamnar de i en media-dre.
Nu förstår jag det lite, jag bara menar att såhär...
Jag försöker identifiera dem redan vid ansäljningsintervjuerna och jag har några frågor som jag ställer och känner mig bekväm med detta.
För att det värsta som kan hända, det är jättesvårt, det har hänt flera gånger att man har fått in rekryteringar som kanske inte har gillat mig eller gillat det vi säger eller gillat Jens.
Det finns tusen saker.
Det är ju hyperviktigt att försöka hitta människor som har skinn på näsan, som har självförtroende.
Det är en av de viktigaste sakerna när jag anställer att man har självförtroende och att man kan sitt jobb men självförtroende är A-I och från en människa som inte har självförtroende de är livsfarliga i en trängd situation.
Ja, jag gillar det.
Du är fruktansvärt värderingsdyd i din, precis som jag hatar när folk säger sånt.
Ska vi prata om det där nu, för man bara gör det per automatik och så tycker man att det är standard på något sätt.
Men du har ju, jag har ju pratat med dig tidigare och jag vet att du gör en del sådana här goda grejer på riktigt.
Jag engagerar mig i de saker jag är intresserad av.
Jag tycker att vi har ett mega problem i samhället med manlig psykisk ohälsa.
Och jag är faktiskt, jag är inte socialdemokrat men gud var jag glad att socialdemokraterna har tagit upp det.
För att liksom, 75% av alla som tar livet av sig män till exempel.
Hade det varit omvänt så hade regeringen agerat.
Men helt plötsligt så är 75% män, de flesta vet inte ens om det.
Men hade det varit 75% kvinnor.
En annan sak jag engagerar mig, det är också liksom, jag har en bakgrund som skattejurist, så jag är engagerad i rättssäkerheten kring skatter.
Men rättssäkerhet generellt tycker jag är också intressant i de frågorna.
Och det ger mig mycket personligen att följa dem och delta i debatten.
Ja, jag bara tycker det är intressant när man vågar gå in så som företagare och faktiskt gå in i lite svårare antal.
Jag måste säga det för det handlar om civilcourage.
Jo, det är lätt att säga.
Det är jävligt svårt att stå för någonting.
Vem är jag och vem är bolaget?
Det finns många bolag härute som är fega.
När det är den presidenten håller man med det och när det är den presidenten håller man med det.
Då vet man att man hela tiden anpassar sig efter makten.
Jag tycker inte om det.
Jag tycker inte att det driver samhället framåt.
Det driver inte oss som människor framåt.
Sedan kan det alltid blamla er i fel också.
Absolut, såklart.
Jag tänkte nästan på slutet så skiter vi alla värderingar här lite grann.
Så går vi på en företagsspråk igen.
Genom lågkonjunkturen så höll ni upp på omsättningen och försäljningen.
Man skulle kunna säga att ni har parerat alla de här svängningarna.
Men ska man vara kritisk så skulle man kunna säga att ni har stagnerat lite grann.
Det kan säkert vara så, eller rättare sagt det är så, våra siffror står ganska stilla.
Men för vår del är det fortfarande lågkonjunktur skulle jag säga.
Återigen våra män, mellan 25 och 55 med ett snitt på 31, intresserade av vitrigspolitik, bor i bostadsrätt eller villa, är hyfsat högt belånade, har mycket pengar på börsen, deras liv går så här just nu och varenda gång det kommer en elräkning så ser vi det i vår försäljning faktiskt.
Det är smarta män om jag får säga det så.
Det är inga spenders.
Den bästa målgruppen har just nu, skulle jag säga Bianca Ingrossos målgrupp.
Lever på studiebidrag, bor hemma eller i en hyreslägenhet.
Vet inte vilket elområde de bor i.
Det här studiebidraget kommer varje månad, man behöver inte bli rädd för att bli av med jobbet.
Det är en väldigt stabil, bra målgrupp.
Vår målgrupp är den sämsta målgruppen har just nu, hur underbar de män är.
Men varför är bräddan inte lite rör?
Jag vet inte, vi är bra på det vi gör.
Jag tycker att vi förändrar vår affärsmodell hela tiden, men det är små justeringar och handlar om att förlänga värdekedjan kanske eller har jobbat jättemycket med bruttomarginaler de senaste åren.
Men om man vet vad allt detta bor på, om man vet varför man inte säljer, och mycket såklart internt hos oss också, vi har tagit vissa fällbeslut om vittan och dattan, men om man vet vad det här beror på den här stagnationen, så kan man också vila ganska lugnt i den kunskapen, och kalibrera sig för nästa fart.
Man behöver inte vara hysterisk om man vet vad det beror på.
Jag köper det.
Jenny, fan, jag tycker att du är jävligt cool.
Jag hoppas folk fick med sig någonting här, och att man fick lite stake efter att ha lyssnat på Jenny.
Men en stor applåd för Jenny som var med här.
Tack så mycket.
Gott folk tar på er er micka nu för fan.
Välkommen, välkommen.
Då har vi min sista gäst här, den vackraste av oss, han som är mest lik Aaron Carter i Backstreet Boys.
Du är Pelle Pettsson som är bakgrund som e-andets chef inom lite alla möjliga bolag får man säga och du har medgrundat byrån Omniarch och du gör lite investeringar och sånt där.
Vi kommer liksom skita i e-andets chefs grejen och Omniarch ganska mycket och så kommer vi fokusera på en av dina investeringar som är smarta saker.
Och jag tror att Ella är här någonstans också i publiken men vi liksom hoppar över henne så går vi direkt till dig.
Man får fråga henne sedan om det vi säger är korrekt.
Kan du berätta lite grann om vad smarta saker är för någonting?
För det första är sjukt kul att vara här.
Tack Joel för att jag fick komma, det känns fantastiskt.
För andra har jag snackat om smarta saker, sjuktkul case.
Jättegott bolag och superspännande.
Smarta saker är egentligen en helt fantastisk idé.
Det handlar om att kurera ett unikt sortiment, oftast från lokala mindre företagare som har kommit med väldigt smarta prylar som ska hjälpa dig i din vardag.
Tanken är ju fantastisk och likadant att man kan stödja lite mindre bolag, också fantastiskt roligt.
Det är grunden.
Sen har det byggt på och det har blivit rätt brett sortiment, men gemensamt är det en unikt kurerat sortiment.
Joel kommer säkert vara dryg och fråga om Temu och sådana grejer.
När vi snackar om det kommer det vara såhär, det som är skillnaden är att det är smarta saker, det är kurerat, det är mer lokalt producerat, det är säkrade produkter och så vidare, kontra massproduktionen som sker i Temu eller Amazon.
Man kan ju ta det här eftersom jag känner till Ella och har pratat en del med henne.
De har till exempel månadens eller veckans uppfinnare där de verkligen visar vem som har gjort den här produkten, kommit på den här.
För när man säger lokalt producerat kan det låta som att det här är från Litauens ytterkan, utan detta är verkligen lokal lokalt.
Exakt, och verkligen hylla de här innovatörerna som kommer med smarta lösningar på saker och ting.
Så det är fantastiskt och väldigt roligt koncept.
Då har vi gjort två minuter sälj där vi har varit snälla mot caset.
På något sätt så finns det en ganska stor overlap mellan detta och när man säger alla konkurrenter från Asien, vi menar egentligen temen när vi pratar om detta, bara för att vara liksom sådär.
Ni har en ganska stor overlap i produkter.
Jag för mig att du pratade om 92% när vi snackade om detta.
Det var ju inte så att du inte fattade detta när du gick in i caset.
Du gick inte in i detta för tolv år sedan, utan det är ju inte så länge sedan.
Är inte det en korkad?
Varför gjorde du det eller kan du bara...
Självfråga.
För det första så är 92% overlap med temor så det är en hyfsad uppmaning liksom, samtidigt rätt kul liksom.
För det är verkligen något att byta tag i.
Och nu kommer jag inte ihåg hur länge det var, två år sedan, ett och ett och ett och ett halvt år sedan jag gick in både i styrelsen och som investerare i smarta saker.
Och det jag såg, det var egentligen några delar, det ena var såhär untapped potential.
Man tittar på, vi hade liksom, Ella och gänget har gjort ett enormt bra jobb men det fanns fortfarande jättemycket kvar att göra på till exempel performance-sidan.
Det fanns mycket att jobba på.
GP1 i inköp, den delen.
Men också det här med att vi har en hyfsat unik position på svenska marknaden, vi har loyal kundmedlemmar och så vidare.
Men vi har också det här unikt kureraresortimentet som jag i alla fall, min tese är att såhär, fler och fler blir mer medvetna om att temogrejer, det är inte skitbra liksom.
Det är ju typ gift liksom i de flesta.
Det tror jag att medvetenheten kommer också att möjliggöra att visst vi konkurrerar mot de här, men så länge vi kan trycka på att våra varor är faktiskt bra grejer, så tror jag också att det finns en usp i det där och kanske till och med vår fördel för att folk kommer att tendera att börja handla mer av grejer lokalt.
Och det tror jag kan gynna en aktör som smarta saker, snarare än missgynna även ifall temo kommer fortsätta få djävligt dryga, trycka upp klickpriser och sådana saker.
Är inte det ett sånt, du vet man övertalar sig själv argument, alltså du hittar det här och så känner du liksom fan om jag gillar detta.
Alltså du vet man blir lite emotionellt engagerad och då börjar man liksom argumentera för att det är en bra tanke.
Absolut, folk blir mer medvetna.
Det är inte så att folk slutar köpa skit eller?
Nej, definitivt inte.
Det kommer ju alla att fortsätta göra.
Men jag tror att medvetenheten ökar och det tror jag kommer att gynna oss.
Sen tror jag också det här med att det finns, återigen nu blir det lite känslare och inte helt matematiskt uträknat, men det finns ju också något fint med att lyfta upp de här innovatörerna, lokalt, oftast mindre bolag.
Om inte vi gör det, vem fan ska göra det då?
Så på något sätt kan jag gynna dem samtidigt som, kommer vi säga att komma in på sämre smarta saker, det har ju börjat gå rätt bra, samtidigt som vi kan ha ett bolag som växer och går rätt bra, då är vi i en win-win situation mer eller mindre.
Så det är att tro verkligen på den kontexten.
Ja, jag köper och det låter som att jag hatar på smarta saker, det gör jag inte såklart.
Jag tycker det är fantastiskt, jag tycker att det är intressant hur man ser på det med investerarglasögon.
Men, som du säger, bolaget har gjort en liten resa här under de två åren.
Vad har ni på riktigt gjort?
Inte så här, aha, vi har fokuserat på vår brandidentity, utan vad har man konkret gjort här under ett par år?
Ja, men det är skitbra.
Gänget på smarta saker har gjort sinnessjukt mycket grejer.
Precis som alla andra e-andesbolag, det jag ser väldigt tydligt, ni har uttryckt många olika e-andesbolag, är att man är offentligt duktig på operations.
Joel, du kan göra ett skitsnyggt nyhetsbrev och skicka det till ett vettigt segment.
Men det jag bidrog med i smarta saker caset var att Ella och teamet, fullt upp med operations, då kunde jag komma in och sätta lite mer, eller bidra med min erfarenhet om vilka stora moves kan vi göra?
Vad kan vi göra på riktigt som faktiskt får effekt?
Tre av de större movesen vi gjorde, det ena var att rätt tidigt fattade vi att det finns en konsolideringsmöjlighet med smarta saker.
Alltså att vi kan köpa upp, antingen köpa varumärken från innovatörer eller kanske köpa någon annan reseller som passar oss och så vidare.
Det första vi gjorde var att köpa upp ett bolag som heter Förvara.se som vi konsoliderar in i smarta saker.
Dels fick vi en produktbräddning i ett sortiment vi tycker är intressant och passar bra in på smarta.
Dels fick vi en massa länkkraft och lite topline på det.
Det där förbättrade också vår GP1, vilket var jäkligt effektivt.
Det andra vi gjorde...
Åh förlåt, då kan vi köra en grej i taget.
Folk säger så att vi ska konsolidera, vi ska köpa in någonting, men det tenderar ju att bli cash.
Varför blev detta bra?
Varför blev det bra?
Det finns några olika sätt att se på det.
Det ena är att konsolidera in bolag i ett bolag som smartar saker.
Det ena är att vi faktiskt gör oss så intressanta framöver för private equity.
Generellt kan vi påvisa att vi är en bra plattform för att konsolidera bolag.
Då blir vi ett intressantare case.
Det finns ett sånt vinkel på det.
Den andra vinkeln är att vi vet att vi ska kunna förbättra vår GP1, köpa upp ett lager, få lite längdkraft och sådana grejer.
Det presterade också väldigt bra när vi konsoliderade in.
Det är mycket jobb.
Det är inte gjort på en kvart.
Men den effekten vi fick var positiv.
Det ser vi också fortsätta rulla ut nu, även om det var ett halvår sen vi förvärvade dem.
Det är en jävla tung framförhållning att tänka att vi förvärvar detta för att kunna visa kapital i framtiden, att vi är bra på att införliva andra bussning.
Jag gillar hur man tänker ett par steg framåt.
Okej, steg nummer två som vi gjorde.
Steg nummer två var att vi insåg att vår butik är rätt viktig.
Vi började titta på vad vi kan etablera fler butiker, och då etablera vi ytterligare en butik på Stockholm Central.
Sjukspännande med den var att efter öppningen på Stockholm Central såg vi en korrelation till ökning i direkt trafik.
Lita av anledningen att vi öppnade den butiken var att vi såg att vi fann klickpriser och allting går upp rätt mycket.
Det blir mycket dyrare med digital media idag.
Och vad händer då ifall vi öppnar upp en butik, den är kostnadsbidragande, vi tjänar pengar på den i slutändan också, men kan den bidra med andra faktorer också som kanske gör att vi inte behöver marknadsföras lika mycket.
Och det vi såg som sagt tydlig korrelation mot ökad direkt trafik, vilket var fantastiskt för sajten också.
Förutom att vi öppnade upp en butik som tjänar lite pengar så fick vi också en ökning i vår digitala trafik också.
Det är ju fajn, jag köper, ni kanske tjänar pengar på det, men det ökar också en absurd komplexitet.
Det är en helt annan grej att driva en butik.
Du ska bemanna alla som har drivit, om någon här har drivit butik, det är ju inte svinkul att bemanna.
Och så ska någon stå där på en lördag och du ska lösa, du måste ha så jävla mycket personal i det plötsligt.
Är det liksom, varför fokusera för lite extra direkt trafik?
Det är en sjukt bra fråga.
Ska alla ha en butik liksom?
Just i smarta caset, positivt där vi hade en butik på Sante Eriksplan, vi kunde jobba med personalplanering mellan butikerna, vilket gav en bra effekt mer eller mindre.
Så den var inte liksom, nu ska jag inte säga mycket, det var Ella som gjorde allt.
Men jag upplevde att komplexiteten var inte enorm.
Sen är det ju en investering, vi måste ju köpa lager, vi måste köpa butiksinredning och så vidare.
Så det blir en investering liksom.
Men i huvudsaken där, min tes är att jag tror att det finns att gynna smarta saker med att öppna ännu fler butiker.
Ja, det är ju, alltså på någonsats, om jag ska gå emot, jag tycker att det är så jävla hype i att alla varumärken ska starta butiker.
Jag tycker att det är en annan affärsmodell någonstans.
Jag vet vi är omnichannel, alla ska jobba tillsammans.
Det är inte riktigt samma sak.
Men jag köper det presentcaset på något sätt.
För man vill gå in och kika, man vill köpa med sig någonting.
Så jag köper det.
Osmarta är som sagt, det är en presentdestination.
Passar det bra på placeringar som centralstationen.
Utmaningen där kanske mot våra andra butik på Sante Eriksplan är att centralstationen där måste vi optimera sortimentet.
Det är ett annat typ av sortiment.
Så vi kan inte köra samma typ av butikupplägg på båda butikerna.
På centralen måste vi jobba mycket mer med lägre priser och enkla varor att ta med.
Och kanske placeringar annorlunda i butik för att optimera kundflödet.
Ja, jag köper det.
Och punkt nummer tre där?
Ja, den tredje delen vi gjorde var att vi såg över hela vår förbolag som smarta saker, hyfsat brett sortiment, återförsäljare, hög konkurrens på produkterna, så performance marketing blir helt avgörande.
Så vi gjorde var att vi byggde om hela performance marketing funneln.
Vilket var sjukt spännande.
Ska jag berätta hur?
Ja.
Okej, är du med nu?
Ja, okej.
Nu går det fort.
Nej, jag skojar.
Men en grej vi gjorde, såhär.
Typ sjuk många bolag idag, som jag sitter med, har kommit ungefär till den graden då de kan optimera sin performance på kanske lönsamhetsnivå, eller i bästa fall orderlönsamhetsnivå.
Och det vi börjat titta på på Smarta var det såhär, okej, hur kan man ta det där nästa steg?
Då kan vi få det ännu bättre, så att vi inte bara optimerar all vår performance.
Jag vet inte ens vad nästa steg är.
Om vi tar all vår performance och optimerar på en orderlönsamhetsnivå i bästa case.
Det är jättemånga som optimerar på kurs fortfarande.
Så det är fortfarande jättemånga som inte är där.
Okej, men om vi ska ta nästa steg med Smarta, vad gör vi då?
Hur kan vi bli ännu bättre?
Då tittar vi på en nivå, nästa nivå, då innebär det att vi tar alla produkter, hyfsat bred produktflora.
Och så tittar vi på fyra parametrar egentligen.
Det ena var hur komplext är köpbeteenden på den här produkten.
Det är olika komplexa köpbeteenden beroende på ifall det är till exempel en, vad ska det kunna vara, någon avancerad dieselverk som du ska ta hem som producerar el.
Det är hyfsat avancerat, du måste fundera rätt mycket innan du köper den.
Det andra är hur avancerat är kundbeteendet, hur svårt är det att vilja köpa den vara mer eller mindre.
Det andra var hur troligt är det att du köper den vara snabbt eller inte.
Så klassar vi in alla de där produktifilmerna, är det en komplex produkt men enkel att handla, eller en komplex produkt som är svår att handla, med eller med komplexitet på produkt och hur enkelt det är att köpa den.
Med eller med utifrån, det går ju att göra ännu fler klasser, men vi börjar med fyra.
Komplex produkt men enkel att handla, handla i ett segment där vi annonserar på ett typ av format.
Det vill säga att vi bygger en specifik funn för den produkttypen.
Klassificeringen gjorde vi helt via någon AI-prompt som vi byggde.
Det innebär att vi har fortfarande ord-
och lönsamhetsparameter i vår performance, men vi lägger till den här som innebär att vissa produkter syns inte ens på Google.
För de ska bara ligga högt upp i funnen för att inspirera dig innan du kanske handlar om.
Och andra produkter annonserar vi inte alls på Meta.
För att den produkten, den vet vi att du är så nära att köpa alltid.
Så det kanske bara är goe shopping att köpa den typen av produkt.
Så beroende på vilken klassificering produkten fick, så fick man också olika kundresor och olika typer av marknadsmixer per produktnivå.
Jag älskar det.
Jag bara, fan det är så jävla logiskt.
För oss har vi, vi säljer fjädelås till skivstänger, och det är inte så att du blir inspirerad på Meta av dem.
Varför har vi ens med den i den jävla produktcarouselen?
Exakt, då kommer ni att betala en massa marketing för den, fast det är helt värdelöst egentligen.
Så där liksom, den konfigurationen börjar vi jobba med nu, för att se, och sen skjuter vi självklart in orderlönsamhet, och CLV-parametrar och allt det där också, men hur kan vi ta det till nästa steg?
Och det blev då den här.
Och det där håller vi på att utvärdera nu.
Det känns som ett sjukt spännande move.
Jag tror att det kommer att bli en positiv, vi tror att det kommer att bli en jättefin positiv halvstånd.
Okej, så ni ska hålla på med det där och sen ska ni kurera sortimentet i de här två butikerna.
Vem är det som ska hålla koll på hela......det där joxet?
Ja men det är ju...
LA teamet är ju fantastiskt.
Det jag kan bidra med är ju kanske så här, vad ska vi göra här nästa?
Vad blir nästa steg nu för smarta saker?
Det är ju skitteftigt för alla de där actions vi har gjort nu.
Smarta saker har ju gått ifrån att ha varit en minusaffär under några år, haft hyfsat tungt, det har varit stor konkurrensomsökning och så vidare, till att nu faktiskt vända den där skutan och börja vända emot i alla fall en neutralt kostnadsenstralt ställe.
Nu ska vi sikta på att få både tillväxt och bli betydligt mycket mer lönsamma.
Nu har vi pratat lite om smarta saker som case.
Men vad är det du, när du går in som investerare i ett bolag, vad är det du går igång på?
Det är inte så att du brukar kika efter, är de en konkurrent till Temu, utan vad är det du letar efter?
Nu har jag kollat på ett gäng, hur många bolag, gemensamt för många bolag är så att de inte, eller i ett tidigt skede skulle jag vilja se betydligt mycket mer siffror än vad de påvisar, CLV, vad har ni för kack?
Fatta de siffrorna är väldigt tidigt, och det är rätt många bolag som inte presenterar det när de ska ta in investeringar, vilket är lite konstigt, för det är ju de parametrarna som man vet får effekt, GM3, hur ser den ut i varje land eller kategori?
Så det är väl ena delen, att fatta siffrorna bakom allting.
Och sen den andra delen är, vem är det som är entreprenören?
För oftast när jag har gått in i bolag så har det varit entreprenörsägda, liksom i huvudsatt early stage eller på väg uppåt.
Men med entreprenören och förstå att jag vill gå in i bolag som det finns en entreprenör som kommer lyssna på mig, som har någon form av growth mindset som man faktiskt kan bolla med och få saker gjorda.
För det värsta för mig vore att investera i ett bolag där ingen lyssnar på mig.
Då kan jag skippa igen.
Vad är gränsen där?
Absolut man har growth mindset men man kan också vara en pushover som bara, ja Pelle du vet allting, gör sig och så blir det ju skit för att du inte känner deras bransch.
Exakt, exakt.
Nej men det måste ju finnas någon typ av samspelig.
Jag kan ju bara, som i smartare caset, det är Ella och teamet som gör allt, jag kan ju bara bidra med mina insikter.
Så länge de har operationell kraft och lite power och är duktiga på det så kommer inriktningen.
Återigen, bolag generellt i Sverige, e-handelsbolag, skitduktiga på operations, skitsnygga niosbrev eller whatever, men de behöver ju oftast hjälp med prioritering.
För oftast gör de saker som inte är värdeskapande.
Det är det som är problemet av så många e-handlare generellt.
Och där kan man ju då komma in och bidra med hur fan ska man prioritera det här?
Vad ska man göra först nu?
Eller vilka move ska vi faktiskt göra som kan få en större effekt än att skruva på Google 2% liksom?
Ja, jag gillar det.
Vad är liksom din...
Jag höll en föreläsning här förut för några timmar sedan och då var min första punkt att man ska hålla fokus och inte hålla på att vara så jävla fladdrig och springa runt och göra massa saker.
Du går ju lite emot den teorin där, så uppenbarligen har jag ju inte rätt liksom.
Men vad är...
Kan man investera i massa olika bolag och ändå vara vettig liksom?
Du driver ju också ett eget bolag och gör...
Ge du kärlek till dina kollegor eller har du bara skit i tråm nu, vart är det?
Det hoppas jag, det får de svara på.
Men jag hoppas det, jag tror att det kan vara trevligt och bra så.
Och bidra med energi framförallt, det tror jag är min styrka.
När det kommer till, jag tror att man kan göra rätt mycket olika saker så länge man liksom har...
Det värsta jag vet, det är typ när man sitter med någon e-handlare eller whatever och så liksom är det inte fullt engagemang i den stunden.
Det jag tror jag kan bidra med, jag kanske inte har jättemycket tid till alla, men det jag kan bidra med fullt engagemang när jag väl är där och då kan man få effekt av det liksom.
Det tror jag är viktiga.
Sen tror jag, jag tror precis som du, jag tror att du har helt rätt Joel, jag tror att man ska fokusera på få saker.
Jag är typ så här, sen 2018 har jag snackat om så här, va fan, gör era performance kanaler de ni har sjukt bra.
Ni behöver inte hålla på och dalta med allting annat.
För det är alltför många som fokuserar på alldeles för många projekt som Robby Halldanna.
Jag tror verkligen att det ligger någonting i fan, gör det ni gör sjukt bra och säkerställa, men säkerställa att ni gör rätt.
Jag tycker att det är en bra avslutningspunkt, så gott folk, om ni ska ta med något från Pelle, gör det ni gör och gör det bra så skit i resten.
Det var rimligt.
En stor applåd för Pelle.
Tack så mycket.
Tack så mycket Joel.
Vad är deras problem?
Det är håravfall, tung svett, fjord svett, nageltång.
Jag kan räkna med en forever.
Hår på ryggen, hår i näsan.
Det finns en oändlig pool av ämnen.